Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2192.
David P, here is a caller making a point about
those who love to say, I've done my research.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: Hi, David.
I think we really need to push back against
people who say they do their own research,
which is this idea that research is something
you can do.
Research is a tool used to describe what you
do.
It's used to describe grant funded activities
costing millions of dollars with tens of thousands
of people involved.
This idea that people are doing research is
absurd.
Okay?
What they're actually doing is consuming information.
Are they critical of that information?
Are they consuming the right kinds of information?
These are the things we need to be discussing.
But when it comes to discussions about should
you do your own research or whatever, it's
absurd because they're using this term research
inappropriately.
Speaker 1: Okay, I get the idea.
So what we're talking about here, this is
interesting.
They're talking about colloquial versus formal
language.
And I'll give you another example.
Many people will often say in casual conversation
or either like a political analyst will say,
I have a theory, or people will write to me
and say, David, I have a theory.
The term theory.
In science means it's a scientific theory,
meaning well substantiated explanation of
some aspect of the world.
We have vast evidence, we have observations,
we have experimentation, logical reasoning.
It's a comprehensive framework that the science
community has said this is the best explanation
we have for some phenomena and it is evidence
based, etc.
It's been tested, it's often been peer reviewed,
etc.
It's been scrutinized.
In casual conversation, when we say have a
theory.
We know that what you mean is you have a hypothesis.
And yeah, sure, to some degree.
Would it be more accurate for people to say,
I have a hypothesis about what's going to
happen in 2024?
Sure, it's more accurate, but sometimes we
use the same words differently when it's colloquial
versus when it's formal.
When we talk about research.
It's true when someone says it, when some
anti-vax person says, I did my research or
when I say it, or whatever the case may be,
we're talking about someone who is gathering
information.
It's it's an it's a information gathering
process with which you then are ideally coming
to some conclusion about phenomena in everyday
life.
Do vaccines cause autism?
Well, I've researched it.
Okay.
But you mean as you gathered information that
others have done other research other people
have done true actual research would be we
are comprehensively and systematically using
established methodologies to generate new
knowledge, and then they are being peer reviewed
and.
Okay, I get it.
Research is a rigorous methodology that most
of us are not doing when we say we're doing
our research.
However, I would focus more on the people
who say I've done my research.
Often what they mean is they read a FoxNews.com
article.
We would do better.
I believe, instead of saying random people
don't do research, you're not working in an
academic research setting or a medical research
setting.
Instead of focusing on that.
I would focus on giving people a better structure
for getting information about topics they're
trying to learn about so they don't end up
on conspiracy websites.
I think we would get more from that, but obviously
the voice mail is accurate in that the term
research means something that is very different
than, you know, sitting at home and looking
at a Daily Wire article.
I agree with that 100%.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about George Santos agreeing
to settle a lawsuit in Brazil.
This is separate from the criminal charges.
We will talk about the North Carolina governor
vetoing a 12 week abortion ban and we will
talk about split juries and the impact and
legacy that this has left in prisons all over
the country.
All of those stories and more are on today's
bonus show, which you can sign up for and
get instant access to that.
Join Pacman.
Okay.
See everybody tomorrow.